اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه اخبار الظهيره
مشاهدينا
ايران من الجيش لدعم الاحتجاجات وتعدم
اربعه اشخاص يدعم ارتباطهم باسرائيل
واشنطن تردد على دعم الاحتجاجات في ايران
معتقلين فرنسيين
واشنطن تتوقعوا استمرار تباطؤ وتيره
القتال في اوكرانيا وتتهم موسكو بالوحشيه
المتعمده
وبلا يطمئنه محبيه على صحته وفي المونديال
السنغال تتحدى انجلترا وفرنسا تواجه
بولندا
اذا مشاهدينا البدايه من ايران حيث اعلنت
وكاله اسنه تنفيذ حكم الاعدام في اربعه
ايرانيين بزعم ارتباطهم بالمساد
الاسرائيلي الوكاله ذكرت ان الايرانيين
الاربعه الذين تم اعدامهم ودونه بالمشاركه
في تدمير ممتلكات خاصه وعامه وذلك
بالتزامل مع الاحتجاجات وبعد محاكمه سريعه
كما حكم على ثلاثه متهمين اخرين بالسجن من
خمسه الى 10 سنوات اعلنت منظمه العفو
الدوليه ان ثمانيه وعشرين ايرانيا من
بينهم ثلاثه اطفال معرضون لخطر الاعدام
مؤكده ان السلطات الايرانيه تستخدم عقوبه
الاعدام للقمع السياسي وايضا لارهاب
المحتجين هذا وقد ذكر تلفزيون ايران
انترناشونال لان وثائق حصلت عليها مجموعه
قراصنه من وكاله انباء فارس طبعا هي تابعه
للحرس الثوري الايراني كشفت عن اعتقاله
115 عنصرا من القوات الايرانيه قوات الامن
الايرانيه لدعمهم الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها
البلاد التلفزيون اضاف ان العسكريين
يمثلون واحد بالمئه من عدد المحتجزين في
الاحتجاجات التي تجهدها ايران طبعا
احتجاجات تستمر للشهر الثالث على التوالي
وقد فشل النظام حتى الان في اخماده لكنه
وفي محاوله لتهدئتها اعلن المدعي العام
الايراني الغاء ما يعرف بشرطه الاداب
دعونا
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا طبعا هذا القرار بالغاء شرطه
الاداب لم يؤثر على التظاهرات حيث اضرم
المحتجون وذلك الليله الماضيه اضرموا
النار في مقر البسيج وذلك بعدد من
المحافظات وايضا المدن الايرانيه اذا عدد
من المدن الايرانيه ولكن في مدينه قدشان
وذلك بمحافظه خراسان محتجون قاموا
بمهاجمه بالمولوتوف هاجموا كما نشاهد من
خلال هذه الصور مكتب امام الجمعه في ما
اضرم اخرون النار في اعلانات حكوميه في
يزد وايضا في داخل العاصمه طهران اي في
ايران
على كل المزيد تنضم الينا من بروكسل
الباحثه في الشان الايراني منى السيلاوي
الاعدامات اليوم في ايران
الرساله من وراء ذلك وهل هي رساله للداخل
ام الخارج
صادقين في الحصول المعلومات عن الجواسيس
الاسرائيليين بالاحرى كان يقدمه معلومات
[موسيقى]
الايراني او خلف سرقه كثير من المستندات
عن الملف النووي الايراني
تبنتهم بالاساس يعني يتبنت هذه العمليتين
ولكن حتى الان
معلومات ما كانوا خلف هذه القضايا كيف تم
اساسا هذه العمليات ولكن الان ياتون باربع
المواطنين ويدعون انهم عملاء اساس انه
يريدون ايضا يوجهون رساله انه هم يواجهون
اسرائيل في داخل الايراني كما هذا اللي
حاضنتهم همم شعبيه في المنطقه يقولون انهم
في مواجهه مع اسرائيل ولكن همم في النهايه
حتى لا نفترض زياده لان هؤلاء اربع عملاء
يعني ما شان شارع الايراني
منتفض يعني حتى
هذه الصور منى اريد ان اعرف معلومات ان
كان لديك اي منها حول ما يحدث داخل هذه
المحاكمات وطبيعه التهم الموجهه وربطها
همم باسرائيل همم تتعلق بتسريب المعلومات
وغيرها من المواضيع لدينا فهم كامل للتهم
الموجوده او لا
يعني تهم دائما جاهزه بالعاده النظام
الايراني يعتقل المعتقل التوهم جاهزه ثم
يقوم بتعذيب المعتقل ومعتقل يقوم باعتراف
يعني هكذا هو طبيعه التعامل حتى عندما
المتهمين اللي لديهم بعض من الجراء او بعض
من الدعم يخرجون في هذه المحاكم ويدعون ان
يتم تعذيبهم القاضي بدل ما يوقف الاجانب
المتهم يتهمه يهاجم اليهم حتى المحققين
يعني حسب روايه الكثير من المعتقلين الذين
خرجوا قالوا المحققين هم من يكتبون الحكم
النهائي ويقدمون للقاضي
تحت التعذيب بالنسبه للاعترافات همم سؤال
في ما يتعلق بانها وصفت هذه المحاكمات
بالسريعه ماذا يعني هذا
يعني في العاده يكون حكم جاهز من قبل يتم
دقايق محدوده المحامي لا يحصل على الاوراق
المحكمه احيانا اوراق المحكمه بالالاف
ويقدم للمحامي قبل ساعات من المحكمه في
بعض من الاحيان حتى المحامي التي ياتي
محامي التي ياتي له يدافع عن المتهم يتم
اعتقاله بحكم انه في حال لم يكن يوافق على
جرائم المتهم لما قابل ان يدافع عن المتهم
يعني هكذا هي طبيعه المحاكم في ايران يعني
كما نتهم بالنسبه
لمحاربه الله ورسوله حتى الان ما في تعريف
دقيق الا يعني ما معناه محاربه الله
ورسوله يتم حكم الاعدام على اشخاص متهمين
همم تحت هذا الحكم لا شك انه همم ننتظر
ردود الفعل في الخارج همم على الاقل على
هذه المحاكمات القي معي مناسبه اتحدث ايضا
عن قضيه ردود الفعل فيما يتعلق بقمع
النظام للمحتاجين في الشارع وطبعا اتساع
رقعه عاهرات المبعوثه الامريكي الخاص
بايران روبرت مالي اعلن ان بلاده تعتزم
التركيز على دعم الاحتجاجات في ايران مالي
وفي تصريحات لوكاله بلومبرج ارجع موقف
واشنطن من الاتفاق لعدم لاهتمام طهران
بالاتفاق النووي لمطالبها التي وصفها بغير
المقبوله مؤكدا ان بلاده لن تتراجع لن
تسمح بتلاعب بها خلال المفاوضات النوويه
التي اصبحت فائدتها على حتى تعبيرها طبعا
امر مشكوك به وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه من
جانبها شددت على الدعم الاحتجاجات في
ايران الى اقصى الحدود الوزاره اكدت على
ضروره ان ينتبها النظام هناك الى الرغبه
الشعب الايراني في التغيير مصدر في
الوزاره اضافه في تصريحا نقله موقع ايران
انترناشونال ان السلطات الايرانيه تواصل
وترهيبه الناس وقمعه حريتهم حتى في الخارج
وفي هذا السياق ندد الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل
ماكرون مجددا بما اعتبره اكاذيب ايرانيه
وابتدا انه مارس ضغطا قويا جدا على نظيره
الايراني الاعتقال النظام رعايه فرنسيين
حسب صحيفه باريزيان قال مكرونه ان
الفرنسيه السبعه الذين اوقفهم النظام
الايراني هم مواطنون ذهبوا الى ايران
احيانا لاسباب اكاديميه او ربما مرتبطه
بجمعيات موضحا بانه مارس ضغطا قويا على
الرئيس الايراني كي يتم احترام حقوقه
هؤلاء كي تكون الزيارات القنصليه ممكن
خصوصا من اجل ضمان اطلاق سراحهم وذلك في
اسرع وقت على كل ان اعود اليك منى وردود
الفعل ابدا بالجانب الامريكي ان كان مالي
او الخارجيه بصوره عامه وتصريحاتها للدعم
لا محدود
للتظاهرات كيف
انا لا اعرف يعني لازم يجاوب كمان انه هو
يصالح ويقول ان الطلب يعني ليس لديه لديها
الرقبه في استمرار في المفاوضات ولا يتكلم
انه ما هي نهايه الموقف المتحده الامريكيه
يعني لو كان الطرف
يدخلون في مفاوضات مع حكومه فاقد الشرعيه
ويكون بقتل المواطنين الاساسي
يعني ممكن تصنف جرائم ضد البشريه ضد
الانسانيه وحتى التطهير العرق يعني طريقه
لتعاملون في اقليم كردستان وقالو شوشان
يعني تقع همم تعاملهم يعني محاوله للهجوم
على الاقليات بهذه الطريقه مع الاسف يعني
حتى ما غيرتها الدول الاوروبيه موقف
الامريكي يعني الديمقراطين جدا ضعيف همم
ما يحصل في ايران طيب موقف ضعيف ولكن هل
هو واضح في ما يؤمل من هذا النظام لانه
الخارجيه تتحدث عن انه يجب على النظام
افهم بالرغبه الشارع في التغيير عن اي
تغيير هنا تتحدث الولايات المتحده
الحكومه الايرانيه لازم تحترم رقبات الشعب
الايراني في حال انه الشعب الايراني لم
يعد يطالب اي شيء من الحكومه الايرانيه
ولا يريد اصلاحات بل يريد تغيير النظام
ولكن حتى الان يعني اظن متاثرين ما زالوا
الديمقراطيين بتحليلات اللوبي الايراني
يظنون في حال تدخلوا في شان الايراني او
في حاله دعم وشارع الايراني سيكون تاثيرات
سلبيه على شارع ايراني والنظام الايراني
يقوم بمزيد من القمع في حال ان النظام
الايراني لا يحتاج الحجاج حتى تقوم في هذه
العمليات العكس الدائعه من اي طرف هو
لصالح الشر الايراني ولكن يعني حسب ما
يبدو انه تحليلهم انه يلتزمون السمك وهذا
صمته يعني هذا عكسيا من بروكسل الباحثها
في الشان الايراني مناسبه شكرا جزيلا لك
طبعا هدفي ما يتعلق بردود الفعل حول
التظاهرات في الداخل ردود الفعل الخارجيه
ولكن دعونا نتحدث عن ما نقل من صحيفه
جوريسلم بوست الاسرائيليه عن تحرك
اسرائيلي هناك تصريحات لرئيس اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي ابيفا كوخافي حول منع تشكيل
حزب الله جديد في ان كان سوريا او العراق
او حتى اليمن وخفي كشف عن عمليه تقوم
بتنفيذها اسرائيل حاليا هناك اي في العراق
وسوريا باسم حزب او حرب الاحرى بين حربين
وتهدف من خلالها الى منع تدشين حزب الله
اخر في العراق وايضا سوريا وتضمنت
المعلومات التي نشرتها الصحيفه ايضا حديث
عن قيام اسرائيل ضربات ضد اهداف ايرانيه
في كل من العراق وسوريا الصحيفه اكدت ان
النفوذ ايران وصل الى قاعده الامام علي
العسكريه طبعا هي قريبه من البوكمال في
سوريا والتي وصفتها بانها مقر عمليات
الفصائل الايرانيه في المنطقه في اخبار
الظهيره ولكن بعد قليل
طائره مسيره تركيه تقتل قائدا عسكريا من
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في الحسكه نتابع
بعد قليل
اهلا بكم مجددا الى اخبار الظهيره ونكملها
من شمال وشرق سوريا وبعد هدوء حظر من
القصف الجوي التركي على مناطق سيطره قصد
استهدف الطائره تركيا مسيره بصاروخين
سيارات بقريه تابعه لمدينه عامودا بريف
الحسكه استهداف ادى لسقوط قتيلين على
الاقل احدهم قيادي وايضا عدد من الجرحى
حيث سرعه سيارات الاسعاف لنقل المصابين
اما في ريف الرقه في الشمال السوري
فاستهدفت القوات التركيه بالمدفعيه
الثقيله اربع قرون وهي عبدك وكوبر لك واا
قزع عليه وفيونكه بريف عين عيسى دون ورود
معلومات عن سقوط خسائر بشريه
الى الملف الاوكراني الان في بعد ان عينه
الامم المتحده فريق تحقيق يدرس ما اذا
كانت هجمات روسي على البنى التحتيه
الحيويه في اوكرانيا ترقى الى جرائم حرب
اتهم وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن
اتهم روسيا بالوحشيه المتعمده في حربها
على اوكرانيا
عمدا وهذا ما يجعل جيران روسيا بحسب
تعبيره ينظرون الى هذا العدوان بقلق شديد
حرب بوتين ليس نتيجه توسع النيترو انها
سبب لتوسع النيترو والان بسبب رغبه
الكريمن لامبراطوريه متلاشيه تواجه اوروبا
اسوا ازمه امنيه لها منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
ان احد اعضاء مجلس الامن التابعي للامم
المتحده يشم حربا لحرمان اكثر من 43 مليون
شخص من الديمقراطيه بوحشيه متعمده
التحتيه المدنيه في مرمى بصرها
وقتلت القوات الروسيه الاف المواطنين
الاوكرانيين
وتسببت الهجمات الروسيه في مقتل الاطفال
وتحطيم المدارس وتحطيم المستشفيات لذا فان
جيران روسيا ينظرون الى هذا العدوان
الامبراطوري بقلق متزايد
بعد اجتماع مع الرئيس الاوكراني
اعتبرت ان الرئيس الروسي
صادقا بشان محادثات السلام مع اوكرانيا
حاليا تصريحات تاتي بعد ان قال الرئيس
الامريكي
مستعد للتحدث مع بوتن لكريم لين رد عليه
بالقول انه ينبغي على الغرب الاعتراف بضم
موسكو المعلن لاربع مناطق اوكرانيه وهو
الرد الذي اظهر عدم جديه روسيا بحسب قول
نولاند هذا ومن جانبه قال الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ان الهيكل الامن الجديد في
اوروبا يجب ان يركز على معالجه المخاوف
الروسيه بشان توسع الناتو وايضا تقديم
الضمانات لروسيا
متابعه
للهيكل الامني المستقبلي الذي نرغب به هذا
يعني ان احدى النقاط الاساسيه التي يجب ان
نتناولها هي خوف روسيا من وجود الناتو قرب
حدودها ونشر الاسلحه التي تهددها ستكون
هذه المساله جزءا من مناقشات السلام
بالاضافه الى حمايه حلفائنا وتقديم
الضمانات لروسيا عندما تعود لطاوله
المفاوضات
الرشد عبد الجواد اهلا بك نبدا بما هو
الحديث الساعه اذا ما صح التعبير
المفاوضات ان كان بالايجاب او بالسلب كيف
تتفاعل هذه همم العناوين في موسكو الان
مرحبا ميسون يعني حديث موسكو حول هذا
الموضوع هو واضح كما ذكروا خلال الايام
الاخيره الماضيه بان المفاوضات مع الغرب
هي مطروحه بشكل كلي لكن لعدم وضع شروط بما
يخص قضيه خروج الجيش الروسي من الجنوب
الاوكراني ومن المناطق التي قامت موسكو
بضمها خلال الفتره الماضيه موسكو طبعا ترى
في المفاوضات حلا لهذا الموضوع
ان كان هناك شروط بهذه القصه في مصر طبعا
ترفض وضع مثل هذه الشروط خاصه تلك التي
تتحدث عن ترك المناطق التي اعترفت بها
موسكو ايضا موسكو تبحث خلال هذه المفردات
يعني اجنده من شانها الوصول الى حلول
بقضيه الازمه الاوكرانيه لذلك طبعا موقف
موسكو لم يتغير كما تحدث عنه الى الاشهر
الماضيه وهو ضروره وجود هذه الاجنده ميسون
ماذا في ما يتعلق بما طرح مكرون حول القوه
الاوروبيه الجديده كيف تتعامل معها موسكو
السياسيه لهذا الموضوع ترى في ان الناتو
حتى هذه اللحظه يقوم بدعم كييف بكافه
الوسائل طبعا ما يلفت الانتباهنا بان يعني
تصريحات جديده ومخيفه كما سمعها البعض
خرجت يوم امس من موسكو تتحدث عن ان الدعم
الاوروبي يعني اصبح الان يطال تلك الاقمار
الصناعيه التي تقوم بتزويد الجانب
الاوكراني بالتحركات وهذا طبعا اعلنت عنه
مصر يوم امس بانه قد يكون انذار من قبل
روسيا والخارجيه كانت قد نوض بانها قد
تقوم بضرب او تعطيل تلك الاقمار الصناعيه
لذلك طبعا نتحدث عنه الرئيس الفرنسي هو
يعني قراءه سياسيه في البلاد بان هذه
القوه هي يعني
مستمره نحو اشهر من الان حول هذا الموضوع
وانا الدعم لان جانب الاوكراني لا يصل لا
المواجهه المباشره مع موسكو لكن هو مستمر
بهذه المعدات الثقيله التي يتم تزويد
الاراضي الاوكرانيه بها ميسون
جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
وافق الاتحاد الاوروبي رسميا على وضع حد
اقصى لاسعار بيع النفط الروسي ليكون 60
دولار للبرميل على ان يبدا التنفيذ القرار
غدا الاثنين الاتحاد الاوروبي في بيان قال
ان القرار سيخفض وبشكل كبير العائدات التي
تجنيها روسيا من النفط بعد ان شنت حربها
على اوكرانيا بدورها اعتبر الرئيس
الاوكراني ان قرار وضع سقف لسعر النفط
الروسي ليس قرارا جديه وفي المقابل اكد
روسيا رفضها تحديد سقف لسعر النفط غدا-
اتفاق الاتحاد الاوروبي ومجموعه السبع
وايضا استراليا
[موسيقى]
تنزيل فيديوهات
المزيد ينضم الينا بالاكياف الصحفي محمد
البابا اهلا بك محمد دعني ابدا في قضيه
تحديد سقف لسعر النفط وتصريحات ازيلانسكي
التي لا يثق فيها بجديه هذا القرار لماذا
شو هي ال ال المعوقات التي يراها او في
عدم ثقه ربنا
هي ليست عدم ثقه ربما يعني الخلاف
بالترجمه تحدث الرئيس الاوكراني بالامس عن
كيفيه التزام الدول
يعني ثقف لي اسعار النفط الروسي حيث يعتبر
ان النفط الروسي كما يراه الجانب
الاوكراني هو الممول الاكبر للعمليه
العسكريه للروسيه التي تقوم بها روسيا
للاراضي الاوكرانيه الرئيس الاوكراني كان
من المطالبين او من اول المطالبين بوضع حد
لسعر النفط الروسي بثلاثين دولار ولكن هل
سيكون ما يتسائل عنه الرئيس الاوكراني
كيفيه
تنفيذ هذه المقررات خاصه ان روسيا بدات
يعني تحاول ايجاد اسواق بديله عن الاسواق
الاوروبيه بعد ما انخفض الى الجانب بنسبه
60 الى 70% انخفض همم الواردات النفسيه
الروسيه من روسيا الى دول الاتحاد
الاوروبيه
عن الوضع الميداني الجديد محمد
قبل الوضع الميداني لابد من الحديث عن
زياره فيكتوريا لولاند وهي يعني
الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه التي يعني تدير
الملف الاوكراني منذ 2014 كان هناك زياره
واجتماع بالامس مع الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي
لمناقشه كيفيه الوصول الى حل تلك الازمه
الجانب الاوكراني يرفض اي وهذا يعني انا
من مصادر من قصر الرئاسه والمقربين من
الرئيس الاوكراني الجانب الاوكراني يرفض
اي حديث عن مفاوضات او اي حلول قبل انسحاب
القوات الروسيه بشكل كامل من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وهذا كان موقف زينسكي بالامس
هو الذي تم ابلاغه لبيكتوريا وكان الرئيس
الاوكراني الى حد منزع عن بعض القرارات او
الحديث من بعض الدول الاوروبيه عن يعني
يدافع اوكرانيا للجلوس الى طاوله مفاوضات
او اي شرح حل
وذلك يعني جاء الرد الروسي وهي تقف عالي
بانه يجب على الدول الغربيه الاعتراف بدمر
روسيا للمقاطعات اما ميدانيه ما حصل
بالامس الجي شرطه القوات الاوكرانيه
بالامس اكثر من محاوله التقدم للقوات
الروسيه في محيط بلده ابن شالكه في
المقاطعه فلوجانز وبريستوف محمود في اجيف
كان مريانكا وفي منطقه تونس الجيش الروسي
شن- حوالي 30 ضربه صاروخيه على مواقع
عسكريه ومدنيه على طول الخط التماس في
قطاع الدنبر وايضا هناك بلده شينكو هذه
البلده في قطاع خلقه التي لديها يعني
تمتلك محول تغيير الطاقه الكهربائيه تم
تدمير هذا المحول مما ادى الى انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي في تلك او في مقاطعه
اشياء الشرقيه
الجيش الاوكراني بدوره 22 مركز مركز تجمع
للقوات الروسيه في قطاع الدوم باص واعلن
عن اسقاط طائرتين من نوع
25 وتدمير ست مسيرات اورلان 10 في منتخب
قطر
شكرا جزيلا لك لهذه المعلومات
في اخبار الظهيره ولكن بعد قليل
اسطوره الكره البرازيليه بلاي يواصل
العلاج من سرطان القولون بالمشفى ويطمئن
محبيه
ايران تعتقل والعشرات من الجيش لدعم
الاحتجاجات وتعدمه اربعه اشخاص بسعم
ارتباطهم باسرائيل
واشنطن تشددوا على دعم الاحتجاجات في
ايران
بشان معتقلين فرنسي
واشنط تتوقعوا استمرار تباطؤ وتيره القتال
في اوكرانيا وتتهم موسكو بالوحشيه
المتعمده
اسطوره الكره البرازيليه بلاي يطمئنه
محبيه في المونديال السنغال تتحدى انجلترا
وفرنسا تواجه بولندا
اهلا بكم مجددا الى اخبار الظهيره وطبعا
نتحدث عن اخبار كاس العالم الان تجاوزت
الارجنتين استراليا بهدفين لهدف ضاربه
الموعد مع هولندا الفائز على المنتخب
الامريكي بثلاثه اهداف
تحيه رياضيه اهلا بكم الى مجاز رياضيه
خلال مباراه الالفي مسيرته الكرويه ميسي
منتخب الارجنتين ربع نهائي البطوله على
حسابي استراليا ضاربا موعد المعاولندا في
الدور ربع النهائيه ميسي يفتتح النتيجه
لمنتخب التانغو في الدقيقه الخامسه
والثلاثين مسجلا هدفه الاول مع بلاده في
الدوري خروج المغلوب خلال المشاركته
الخامس في البطوله قبل ان ياتي الدور في
الدقيقه 57 على زميلي ونجم مانشستر سيتي
جوليا على البراز الذي استغل خطا من
الحارس الاسره لماتشورايان مسجلا الثاني
اهداف بلاده لكن المنتخب الاسترالي تمكنا
في الدقيقه السابعه والسبعين من تقليص
النتيجه عبر انسوا فرنانداس بالخطا في
[تصفيق]
المنتخب الهولنديه دور 16 بنجاح الى ربع
نهائي بعد فوزه على نظيره الامريكيه
بثلاثه اهداف لهدف صنع اول هدفين وسجل
ثلاثه الهدف الثالث الحاسم ليقوده هولندا
للفوز امام الكثير من ارب اكثر من 44000
متفرج الطواحين افتتحوا التسجيل في اول
عشر دقائق باقدام نافذ ديكوبا قبل نهايه
الشوط الاول اضافه هدفهم الثاني بنفس
السيناري عبر داني بلانيت ونجح المنتخب
الامريكي في تقريص الفرق عبر البديل هاجي
رايت في الدقيقه السادسه والسبعين لكن بعد
خمس دقائق حسب ما تنزل الامور وعزوز
النتيجه بهدف الثالث في الدقيقه الحاديه
والثمانين ستلعب هولندا التي فازت امام
اكثر من 40 44000 متفرج في دور الثمانيه
مع الارجنتين
[تصفيق]
وتسعه فرنسا الى استعاده فريقها ومواصله
حمله الدفاع عن لقبها عندما تراقب ولند
الطامحه بتركيب بصمه في هذا المنطقه
فرنسا حامله اللقب بدات مونديال قطر وهي
تخشى تكرار سيناريو 2002 والخروج من دوري
المجموعات
الديوك هو قبل صافره البدايه تلقوا ضربه
موجعه بغياب صاحب الكره الذهبيه كريم
بنزيما للاصابه المباراه الافتتاح امام
استراليا قالب فيها الناتج الفرنسيون
للفوز برباعيه
مره اخرى احد ركائز المنتخب يغادر المعسكر
الاصابه وهو لوكاس هيرنانديز اللقاء
الثاني امام الدنمارك شهد فوز الازرق
بثنائيتك ليان مبابي
يتلقى المنتخب الفرنسي الخساره بهدف وهبي
والمكسيك اربعه نقاط فقط جعل الزملاء
ليفاندوفسكي يجتازون المجموعات المنتخب
لقاء واحد جمع البولنديين والفرنسيين في
مسابقه الدوليه وكان ذلك في كاس العالم 82
في اسبانيا لحساب مباراه تحديد المركز
الثالث والذي شهد تفوق النسور بثلاثه
اهداف على زملائي
في مباراه الثانيه ستلعب انجلترا مع
السنغال في دور 16 على ستاد البيت في
الخور
الانجليزي
كره القدم منذ 56
البطوله واستمرت الى قبل مواجهه ثمن
النهائي وهو الرجل الذي قاد انجلترا الى
نصف نهائي البطوله الماضيه ونهاء النسخه
الماضيه من كاس اوروبا
اما المهاجم راشفورد فيبدو انه السعاده
ثقته بنفسه مع المنتخب بعد ان كان احدا
اللاعبين الثلاثه الذين اضعوا ركله
ترجيحيه امام ايطاليا في نهائي اليورو
اصبح احد المفاتيح المهمه في خط الهجوم
الانجليزيه
السنغال بطل افريقيا تمكن من تخطي دور
المجموعات للمره الثانيه خلال ثلاثه
مشاركات له فقط مدربه اليوسي سي عرف كيف
يستغل قدرات لاعبيه الذين ينشطون في اقوى
وابرز الفرق الاوروبيه المدرب السنغالي
يسعى لمعادله افضل انجازا للكره
السينغاليه في المونديال بالوصول الى ربع
النهائي وهو كان احد اعمده المنتخب كما ان
التجديد عقده قبل ايام من انطلاق المنافسه
ساعد السيسي في التركيز بشكل افضل على
تقديم اداء جيد خلال المباريات فهل تثبت
اسود التي المنتخبات الافريقيه باتت رغما
صعبا في البطوله ام ان واقعيه الانجليز
ستنهي المغامره السنغاليه
[موسيقى]
منذ المباراه الاولى قدم اغويرو الرد
الافضل على كل ما مر به لقد قدم اداء
مذهلا في المباريات الثلاث التي خاضها حتى
الان وعلينا مواصله البناء لعبت الى جواره
في العديد من المباراه الدوليه وعشنا معا
العديد من اللحظات ولا يستحق ما مر به مع
ناديه
المهمه يوم الجمعه
الارشادات اللازمه وما علينا القيام به
ناموا ان يكون متواجدا في الملعب يوم
المباراه وان يقود الفريق من ارض الملعب
هدفنا هو الصعود وانا متاكد ان اللاعبين
سيكونوا جاهزين ومستعدين ستكون مواجهه
صعبه لكن علينا ان نحافظ على الهدوء
منتخب السنبا بعد مباراه الخشنه امام
الكاميرون خرج باصابتين هما المهاجم
غابريجيسوس والمدافع اليكس تالس كلفتهما
توضيح البطوله مثل ما اكده السبت المسؤول
الاعلامي للاتحاد البرازيلي جسوس شعره في
مباراه بالام دفعت المدرب الى استبداله
واخر تقارير تفيد الى حاجته لشهر للتعافي
بينما يحتاج اليكس ستانلس لعمليه جراحيه
بعد ما ترك الملعب مصابا وهو يبكي اثر
اصطدامه باحد لاعبي الكاميرون تتضمن قائمه
المصابين المنتخب البرازيلي كل من الظهير
الايمن دانيلو وظهير الايسر اليكس ساندرو
ونجم الفريق نيمار
كان هذه ابرز اخبار المدير شكرا لمتابعتكم
تحيات شكرا ليليان ونكمل من الرياضه
وبالتزامن مع المواجهه التي تنتظر منتخب
فرنسا وبولندا اليوم على ملعب اسمامه ضمن
منافسات دوري 16 من كاس العالم 20 22 توقع
الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون في تصريحات
لصحيفه باريزيان الفرنسيه فوز فرنسا على
بولندا بنتيجه
3-1 وبلوغ الديوك ربع النهائي وعن مسجلين
الاهداف قال ماكرون ربما يسجل ليفاندوفسكي
لبولندا ويحرز لنا همم باقي وجمهول اهداف
والاخير يريد صناعه التاريخ مشيرا الى ان
لاعبي المنتخب الفرنسي تماسك رغم الغيابات
العديده وصدمه اصابه كريم بنزيما على
الخاص على كل من جهه اخرى اعلن مستشفى
البرت اينشتاين في ساو باولو ان اسطوره
كره القدم البرازيليه بلاي هو الذي يبلغ
من العمر 82 عاما سيبقى في المستشفى خلال
الايام القليله المقبله لمواصله العلاج من
سرطان القولون مضيفا ان الحاله الصحيه
العامه له تتحسن
[موسيقى]
والمزيد معنا من دبي الرياضي مراد المصري
سابدا بما انتهينا به ما يتعلق
وردود الفعل خبرني عن ولاءات الجمهور هل
هي ثابته او لا
مصطفى يعني ليه هو حاله خاصه بالنسبه
للجماهير يعني سواء ان تحب البرازيل او لا
تحبها يعني نتذكر هو ممكن اخر اساطير
الزمن الجميل يعني
نشانا على اسم بنيه لاعب سجل اكثر من 1000
هدف في مسيرته اكثر لاعب توجه لكاس العالم
ثلاث مرات يعني رقم اعجاز تقريبا بغض
النظر ومن يريد منه يعني حتى انه كان له
دور مجتمعي في وحده الاوقات في افريقيا
اوقفه في الحرب الاهليه عندما خرج مباراه
كره القدم شارك في افلام سينمائيه يعني
دائما كان جزء في حياتنا عندما كبرنا
بالرقم عشره
ونتمنى له الشفاء مراد سانتقل الى ما ذكر
مكروه توقع همم فوز فرنسا ثلاثه واحد ماذا
عنك ماذا تتوقع
اه يعني اعتقد انه ما انتظار دور 16 خلاص
المفاجات ستكون نادره للغايه المستحبات
الكبيره ستحقق المطلوب منها يعني دوري
المجموعات احيانا يكون هناك في اختبارات
تبديلات في التشكيل لحتى يعني لا نريد
التقييم الفون سينا تونس على فرنسا ولكن
فرنسا ممكن تعاملت على الطريقه مختلفه
حاليا خلاص بدا الجد لا المنتخبات الكبيره
تريد ان تحقق المطلوب منها وهذا ما
شاهدناه مع انطلاق الدوري الثاني امس فوز
الارجنتين وهولندا يعني خلص بدات
المنتخبات هذه المرشحه تريد تحقيق المطلوب
منه وان كانت مهمه فرنسا الصعبه لانه في
14 محاوله سابقه
دائما تمكن حامل اللقب من الفوز فيه مرتين
متكلمتين يعني مهمه صعبه للغايه ولكن
فرنسا ما زالت من ضمن ممكن ثلاث مرشحين
اخوه يعني المناقشه
فرنسا اتوقع
حدد بقول لك ثلاثه واحد
منظم حتى امام السعوديه يعني اعتمدت على
الاعداء يعني الدفاعيه للتسجيل يعني لا
تبدو هناك الفريق منظم يعني للغايه في هذه
البطوله ويبدو بعيد عن المنافسه طيب خبرنا
عن اداء الامس
كلاهما في اخر مشاركات خاصه بهما بلغم دور
ربع النهائي خمس مرات من اخر ست مرات
دائما
ولكن
في كاس العالم يعني الارجنتين من الشركه
80 دائما لديها اجيال واسماء وتحديدا لجان
الحالي مع ميسي ولكني احقق رغم انه
مشاركته تحديدا واعمال 2016
كره القدم اكثر من مليون و200,000 لاعب في
البلاد وان انجازات في اوروبا والانديه
وغيرها يعني المواهب ودائما في المونديال
تسقط في الخطوات الاخيره اعتقد انها
مباراه مثيره للاهتمام ومن يستحقق الفوز
سيكون كبيره ممكن يبلغ النهايه بالنسبه
للغيابات وخاصه ايضا اشار لها انه رغم
الغيابات استطاع المنتخب الفرنسي تحقيق
الفوز الغيابات بصوره عامه في هذا
المونديال كيف قيموه هل هو طبيعي يعني
بنفس الوتيره التي حدثت في السابق
كاس العالم مض
بوطه من اجل انه كاس العالم ياتي في نفس
الموسم هذا اثر اللاعبين ادى عدد الاصابات
الكبيره للغايه غياب كريم بنزيما له يعني
ايجابيات
وسلبيات هو
افضل فرنسا حققت اللقب في غيابه وبين
مجموعه تقريبا الحاليه في الوقت الحالي
يعني فهي متجان اذا كان شعرها حاليا
لم يظهر نفس التجانس في امم اوروبا على
سبيل المثال بموجوده فبالتالي اعتقد انه
ربابه النافع لمنتخب الفرنسي
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
نكمل المشاهدين من اليمن حيث قال وزير
الاعلام اليمني معمر الارياني قال ان
استهداف جماعه الحوثي لمسجد في محافظه
الحديده بطائره مسيره اثناء صلاه الجمعه
جريمه حرب مكتمله الاركان اضاف الارياني
على تويتر ان الهجوم اسفر عن مقتل مدنيين
واصابه خمسه اخرين من بينهم اطفال اكد ان
الهجوم الاخير يضاف الى سلسله الجرائم
التي ترتكبها جماعه الحوثي واستهدافها
المنهج للاحياء السكنيه والمنازل والمساجد
والاسواق العامه بهدف الايقاع باكبر قدر
من الضحايا بين المدنيين وذلك في ظلمه
وصفه
الدولي غير مفهوم وفي خبر اخر اقامه مركز
البحر الاحمر للدراسات السياسيه والامنيه
مائده مستديره لمناقشه اوراق بحثيه حول
الدور الداعم لليمن من قبل كل من السعوديه
وايضا مصر توصيات الحاضرين تمحورات حول
اهميه وقف القتال ازاله الالغام وبعض ذهب
الى استخدام الطاقه كا ورقه ضغط لفرد
اليمن على اولويات الاجنده الدوليه دعونا
متابع
خبره رافعه المستوى اكتملت في القاهره
لمناقشه شركه السعوديه المصريه لحمايه
الامن القومي العربيه اليمن نموذجا والتي
ناقشت عدد من الاوراق البحثيه الهامه في
هذا الشان منها ما كان معنيا بالتدخلات
الخارجيه وحمايه الوطن العربيه منها
واضحه ومعروفه انها تهديدات ايرانيه في
اليمن لكل المنطقه العربيه وبالذات
السعوديه
وفي اطراف جديده
[موسيقى]
الصين في الموضوع
نسرين لها وضع كبير
مشروع مسام لازاله الالغام ولكن هذا
الموضوع عرج بالحديث على عدد من الالغام
الاكثر اهميه من وجهه نظر المشاركين
امريكا وبين ايران بس الواحد لما يتامل
المساله بعمق جدا يجب انه تم تدعم الايه
الجهود الايرانيه في تفكيك المنطقه عمليه
التفكيك هذه احنا لابد ان احنا ننظر اليه
على انها انغام بتظهر في جسد العروبه
التوصيات طماح ورد حول ضروره استخدام
اوراق الضغط العربيه لوضع اليمن على راسها
الاولويات الدوليه
النيه عندها اوراق ضغط حقيقيه
متخصصه من القوات المسلحه المصريه
والسعوديه
لرفع الالغام في المناطق التي يتفق عليها
تحت مظله الجامعه العربيه
وتختر كل الاطراف المعنيه بانها مستعده
للبدل فورا في رفع هذه
ضروره انهاء القتال اولا قبل الحديث عن
ازاله الالغام والا سيكون امرا لا ينتهي
تامر نصره العربيه القاهره
مشاهدينا الى لارا الان واخبار الظهيره
الاقتصاديه
مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد اذا
تداولات سوق الاسهم السعوديه وبقيه
الاسواق الخليجيه ان احدثها الان السوق
السعوديه بعد بدايه ايجابيات تعود لتسجل
تراجع اليوم في 0.2% صوره افضل في بقيه
الاسواق الخليجيه لن ننسى من السوق على
مدار الاسبوع الماضي كان فيها خسائر بواحد
بالمئه وايضا على مدار الشهر الماضي خسائر
وصلت الى سته ونص بالمئه على مؤشر السوق
السعودي ارام كل يوم تتراجع بثلاث اعشار
بالبيئه في تراجع باسعار النفط في نهايه
الاسبوع ولو انه الاسعار سجلت ارتفاع على
مدار الاسبوع الماضي اكيد متابع اليوم
اجتماع مهم لاوبيك بلاس اجتماع افتراضي من
غير المتوقع ان تغير المجموعه من سياسه
الانتاج نحن نعرف انه المجموعه اقرت مؤخرا
ااه تخفيض انتاج بيبي مليونير الامر الاخر
اللي تبعناه مؤخرا في اسعار النفط هو
موافقه مجموعه السبع واستراليا
على وضع السقف لسعر النفط الروسي الذي
يباع والمنقول بحرا ثم وضع السقف عند 60
دولار روسيا قالت بانها لن تقبل بذلك وسوف
تاخذ اجراءات همم سوف تعلن عنها لاحقا
اسعار برنت ونايمكس على مدار الاسبوع اذا
كما تحدثنا ارتفاعات اول مكاسب بعد ثلاث
اسابيع من التراجع ولكن يوم الجمعه سجل
لنا تراجعات وايضا اتجاه نزولك نعم بنشوفه
على اسعار النفط بسبب كذلك الاغلاقات في
الصين اللي بتاثر على الطلب لانه الصين هي
اكبر مستورد للنفط في العالم همم هذا كان
عم باثر سلبا ايضا تداعيات وكنا بنشوفها
على سوق الاسهم السعوديه سابك ضمن قطاع
المواد الاساسيه مرتفعه اليوم متقدمه ايضا
ارتفاعات بواحد فاصل سبعه بالمئه اشارك
حصلت على موافقه وزاره الطاقه همم شركتان
لها حصلت على موافقه وزاره الطاقه على
انشاء وتملك خط انابيب لنقل البروبلين في
الجبيل لمده 25 سنه هجريه س تفعل بشكل
ايجابي مع هذه الاخبار
اسهم البنوك اليوم ضعيفه بشكل عام ما عدا
الاهلي يسجل الارتفاعات باربعه عشر بالمئه
واسهم الاتصالات ايضا ضعيفه اليوم اس تي
سي تخسر اربعه اشهر بالبيئه زين الان ما
حد كل الارتفاعات ام ينتد من الاكثر
ارتفاعا الشركه تعلن عن موافقه الهيئه على
طلب زياده راس مال عبر طرح اسهم حقوق
اولويه تطرح او تنوي رفع راس مالها ب 346
مليون ريال الى 445 مليون ريال رفعه كبيره
لانه راس مال الحالي هو واقل من 100 مليون
ريال مشاهدينا انا بالطبع اقعد معكم بعد
قليل في الاسواق العربيه للتحدي لتحديث
هذه الارقام دعونا ننتقل الان مجددا الى
ميسون شكرا لارا
رقم من مصر مشاهدينا لا يزال التفاعل
مستمر حول مشاهد الاعتداءات التي تعرض لها
الطاقم التمريض في مستشفى قويس العام في
ما اعلن وزير الصحه ان هناك تحقيقات حول
الواقع وانه لا يوجد احد فوق القانون
[موسيقى]
الطبيه والتمريضي واكد ان القضيه قيد
التحقيق وانه لا احد فوق القانون
بيانا فيه ان القوات المسلحه عن القضيه
وتاكد كامل احترامها لسياده القانون وتهيب
الجميع تحري الدقه وانتظار انتهاء
التحقيقات وفي منزلها التقينا بالسيده مها
بشر احدى الممرضات المعتدى عليهم حيث اكدت
انها هي وزميلاتها تعرضنا للاهانه وانهن
يطالبون بالعدل وانهن في انتظار انتهاء
التحقيقات وتضحي كافه الحقائق بعيدا عن
الشائعات التي انتشرت على صفحاته مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعيه
احنا عايزين حقنا لهنا اللي احنا فيها ديت
عايزين حقنا ردي اعتبار دي اشاعات فيس في
صور اللي نزل الكلام ده ما فيش زميلتنا
مفيش حد عندنا حامل ما فيش حد عندنا سيت
احنا ما فيش حد هنا حامل
التقينا باحدى الممرضات التي طالبت بضروره
توفير الحمايه للتواقم الطبيه من مثل هذه
الاعتداءات
يعني مش مش طالعين الاهانه
بعد ظهور الفيديوهات وتصريحات من اسره
الطيار تشير الى ان بعد افراد المستشفى هم
بداروا بالاعتداءات على المريضه واسرتها
احنا قدام روايتين واحنا دلوقت قدام جهتين
تحقيق النيابه العسكريه بيتحقق والنيابه
العامه بيتحقق في انتظار التحقيقات
الرسميه لاعلان النتائج والان يبقى الجميع
في انتظار انتهاء التحقيقات من كافه
الاطراف لكشف الحق وحسم الجدل ومعاقبه
المتسببين في واقعه اعتداءات مستشفى
قويسنا العام التي شغلت الراي العام احمد
عثمان العربيه مدينه قويسنا محافظه
المنوفيه
اخيره الى ارتفاع حالات الاصابه بالفايروس
المخلوي التنفسي مصحوبا بارتفاع نسب
الشفاء منه في الولايات المتحده اسندت
مراكز طبيه امريكيه السبب في ذلك الى
تكوين مناعه بسبب تكرار الاصابه بمتحورات
فيروس كورونا لكنها في الوقت ذاته حذرت من
زياده اعداد الحالات التي همم تستقبل في
المستشفيات
ارتفاع في حالات الاصابه لكنه مصحوب
بارتفاع مماثل في حالات الشفاء صوره رسمه
خبراء صحيون لمشهد الفيروس المخلوي
التنفسي ار اس في
وفقا للخبراء فين الاصابات السابقه بفيروس
كورونا ومتحولاته ساعدت في تكوين مناعه
جماعيه في مواجهه الفيروس المخلوي التنفسي
جانب ايجابيه عكسته العلاقه بين فيروس
كورونا وار اس بي لكن لم تزل التخوفات من
تدايات المرض خاصه مع تسجيل ارتفاع في
دخول المرضى الى مستشفيات الولايات
المتحده
حيث سجل الدخول نحو 80 الف طفل دون سن
الخمس سنوات
ووافقا للمراكز الامريكيه لمكافحه الامراض
والوقايه منها تم تسجيل ما بين
6000020 الف حاله دخول الى المستشفى بين
كبار السن ومن الولايات المتحده الى
المانيا التي دقت ناقوس الخطر بعد ما اصيب
اكثر من سبعه ملايين شخص بامراض الجهاز
التنفسي المختلفه في غضون شهر واحد
وذلك وفقا لمعهد روبرت كوخ الالماني الذي
اشار الى دوري الفيروس المخلوي التنفسي في
ارتفاع معدلات الاصابه ارقام واحصاءات
ترصد بينما تعكف المراكز البحثيه على
تطوير اللقاحات ضد الفيروس المخلوي
التنفسي الذي قد يصيب مرضه اكثر من مره في
موسم واحد والى ذلك الحين ينصح الاطباء
كافه الاجراءات الوقائيه خاصه بعد تحذير
منظمه الصحه العالميه من ان الفيروس
المخلوي التنفسي يعد تهديدا للمستشفيات
علي السمان العربيه
توفي الاعلاميه والصحفي المصريه الكبير
مفيد فوزي عن عمر الناهزه 89 عاما بعد
رحله معاناه مع المرض حيث امض ما يقارب
الشهب شهر تقريبا باحد المستشفيات الخاصه
كانت صحته الاعلاميه المصريه الراحل قد
تدهورت مؤخرارا حيث خضع لعمليه جراحيه
تضمنت تركيب قسطره ودعامه في القنوات
الى العناوين
ايران تعتقل ولا عشرات من الجيش لدعم
الاحتجاجات وتعدمه اربعه اشخاص بدعم
ارتباطهم في اسرائيل
بشان معتقلين فرنسيين
واشنطن تتوقع استمرار تباطئ وتيره القتال
في اوكرانيا وتتهم موسكو بالوحشيه
المتعمده
اسطوره الكره البرازيليه بيليه يطمئنه
احمد محبيها وفي المونديال السنغال تتحدى
انجلترا وفرنسا تواجه هولندا
انتهت النشره نلتقي في دبي قريبا مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]